hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to
this f i am not any farther i had meant
to start this when i got farther along
but that wasn't gonna happen so just
bear with me as i get
back to where i was
no stop bouncing see i don't do that
bounce i do not do that bounce
that bounce is a result of the camera
moving and
recoiling which is the stupidest
mechanic i've ever seen
in any game because i can't account for
the camera recoil
it's like never mind just
never mind no no
no no no not like that not like that
not like that not like that
please don't please do not stand at my
grave and cry
i am not there i did not die
mary fry god the [__] camera bounce i
[__] hate it so much it is to suffer
to survive is to find some meaning in
this oh my god
no i just [__] fly
i just [__] did that
i'll be right back hang in there don't
let it get to you
shut the [__] up you shut the [__] up
you shut the [__] up you shut the [__]
up i hope you
die in a fire shut the [__]
up oh god
stop going around that [__] way
stop going around no
no no no no no ah
ah oh
all this tom [__] all this tom
[__] all of this tom [__]
i hate it so much okay i hate it so much
oh no no no no very gentle very gentle
very gentle very gentle
my arm is starting to compensate for the
rocking
but i've been rubbing my wrists so much
on my mouse pad
that it's starting to wear into my the
meat of my palm
it is this this game is damaging me in
so many ways
i'm gonna have an aneurysm i'm gonna
have a heart attack
my wrists are gonna fall apart
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
we gotta set down set
down and then launch
grab no no okay just like that
now i know most likely you're watching
this on youtube no twitch
no some dude with 10 million views does
it for you
being fed chewed up food that's culture
too
shut up no no
no
see that bounce that bounce that sudden
launch upwards
that's not my doing at all just the
camera
so i have to come dirt
is a mosaic of pleasure and power grief
is an interval between two moments of
joy
peace is the interlude between two walls
without a thorn the diligence this is
what drives people to turn into
werewolves
and that's a choice not a curse i hate
this game
so much this is the worst game i've ever
played in my entire life
i've never hated the game more than this
game
and it's [__] pretentious oh it's
hard therefore it's rewarding
no it's hard because it's [__] and
you made it that way
so you [__] know it's [__] it's
not
any wonder of game development no you
made it [__]
because you know how to make a game
[__] you're not a [__]
prophet because you made a hard game
patience and then attacking
scraping then flapping and snagging
you are no saint you are not better than
me
just because you made a [__] game
you are not
you are not sorrow is my own yard
where the new grass flames as it has
flames shut up shut up
not with the cold shot shut up shut up
i know you know you're making it worse i
know you know you're making it worse
with your [__] quotes
from people who are actually
contributing to society when they were
alive
which is not you developer of this game
you are doing nothing just the same as i
am you
and i are the same temporary [__]
piece of human organism
that we all know and hate
we all know
you piece of [__] if you will not get up
this goddamn mountain
what why did you do that why
did you do that no ah
i almost fell again you [__]
no no why why why
why when i'm right there i know what to
do
why [__] the different rates of
acceleration
affect your goddamn swing
oh my god i hate it so much
every part of me i know how to go up i
do
i know how to control this piece of [__]
i do i know it i get it i get it i
completely and utterly get it i do
i understand it intimately the only
thing i can't get
is the [__] randomization with the
camera
the speed at which
no i had
shut the [__] up shut up i hate you all
right here i am
again you remember this place yeah i do
so let's just take this
nice and gently
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no don't
don't don't pull in
oh god that one was my fault that one
was my fault
that was my fault i shouldn't have i
shouldn't have tried to go for it
what i've how
[Music]
why why why why
why that doesn't make any [__] sense
as to why the [__] you decided
to be a piece of garbage
no god [__] damn it
i'm not even i'm not even like anguished
anymore i just expect
[__] to be dealt to me why oh god
oh oh my god
no why don't that would have sent me
right back down
you piece of [__] you know that would
have you know that would have
game you are freaking messing with me oh
everybody is a winner in your
eyes every because everybody loses at
the same rate
oh [__] you [__] you
okay up here that's great this is great
this is great i'm thinking positive
thoughts
i'm thinking about positivity and love
which i have an abundance of you know
why
because i'm [__] out of my goddamn
mind that's why that's why
because i'm out of my [__] mind
why oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god
oh my god
[Music]
okay i'm here now that's interesting
yeah yeah yeah
okay
no just set down on it
just set down there we go
ah
nope no no no no no no no no
no no why are you not
wait wait wait wait
no no no no
oh no you tricked me you [__] piece
of [__] you tricked me
you tricked me into thinking that my
hammer was stuck [__]
you no no not the dog
i've all said words
[Music]
[__] you tricked me you stuck my
goddamn hammer and you [__] tricked
me
you [__] tricked me you piece of [__]
game
you piece of [__] you [__]
piece of [__] how could you
[__] do that to me oh
calmly and rationally
but on the off chance that you're
playing this what i'm saying is
trash is disposable but maybe it doesn't
have to be approachable
what's the feeling like are you stressed
i guess you don't hate it if you got
this far
feeling frustrated [__] it's underrated
[__] you and your
poetic [__] no one cares
no one cares no no one cares
about anything oh this is supposed to be
like a checkpoint i know
so don't [__] with me don't
[__] with me do not i will end you
i will end everything there is to know
about you
an orange is sweet juicy fruit locked
inside a bitter peel
that's not how i feel about a challenge
i only want the bitterness
it's coffee it's grapefruit it's
licorice
[Music]
okay so i just gotta push this orange
out of my way
first get out thank you oh boy
oh boy
so this is a challenge
no please audiences uncritically
accepting their tastes
it can only mean that you have no
respect for them
andre takovsky oh my god that one hurts
so bad that one just hurt you
[__] [__]
i'm gonna cry i'm gonna cry because
you're such a piece of
[__] that is not what i wanted to do
and you [__] know it you know it you
piece of [__] game
no
you get me [__] emotionally
compromised
this is what you wanted this is what you
[__] wanted
it's what you [__] want you piece you
say
you sadistic piece of [__]
[__] you [__] you [__] you [__] you
[__] you [__] you [__] you
[__] you i'm done i'm
[__] done with your [__] game i'm
done this is
[__] i cannot do it i can't do it
okay i'm gonna do it okay i'm gonna keep
going but i have to take
like a week off from this [__]
because i can't do it i'm gonna tell the
world
about how [__] this game is right
now
if you remember this tweet from the past
you know that this is the moment
this is the moment that i tweeted this
right now
i hate getting over it with every fiber
of my being
no game has left me with more hatred
in my heart i urge every single person
alive to stay as far away from it
as humanly possible and i now have
a full-blown full-blown migraine
at the rage i have felt for this
this demon in the form of a game and
there you have it
i hate you biffordy mumblo bifferty
fibble
you're the worst in the world thank you
everybody so much for watching
if it makes you feel better pretend i
love this game
pretend i'm having a good time pretend
pretend it's all i can do and as always
i will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
yep
now